♪ [music] ♪
Give me one minute and I'll show you
how BigQuery can help you
get insights from your data, fast.
BigQuery is Google Cloud's
enterprise data warehouse,
designed to help you ingest, store,
analyze, and visualize data with ease.
You can ingest data into BigQuery
by uploading in batch
or by streaming data directly,
enabling real-time insights.
As a fully-managed data warehouse,
Google takes care of the infrastructure
so you can focus on analyzing your data
up to petabyte scale.
BigQuery supports a standard SQL dialect
that is ANSI compliant,
so if you already know SQL,
you're all set.
Interacting with BigQuery is easy.
You can use the Cloud Console UI,
BigQuery command-line tool,
or use the API with client libraries
of your choice.
When it comes time to visualize your data,
BigQuery integrates
with several business intelligence tools
to help you turn complex data
into compelling stories.
The pricing model is simple.
You pay for data storage,
streaming inserts, and querying data.
Loading and exporting data
are free of charge.
Storage costs are based
on the amount of data stored.
For queries, you can choose
to pay per query
or a flat rate for dedicated resources.
So next time you're looking
to analyze data, big or small,
take a minute and look at BigQuery.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/BigQuery.